kevin o'leary the star of abc's shark
tank recently spoke at the bitcoin
conference and he made a bold bold
prediction kevin was talking about the
fact that we need some sort of
regulatory clarity we need policy to be
well understood by institutional
investors they have trillions of dollars
of assets that they want to pour into
this industry but without that clarity
they won't do it here's kevin talking on
stage yesterday explaining this exact
point when we get policy and the
regulator regulates that's not a
negative thing
the spigots of capital
are going to flood into this sector
like you've never seen and so for those
of us that can invest in it now you're
getting ahead of what's going to be a
huge wave of interest when policy occurs
i predict in the next 10 years that
crypto blockchain
bitcoin
all of this innovation
will be the 12th sector of the s p
now why do i say that because
bitcoin is not a coin it's software
ethereum is software avalanche is
software helium is software salon is
software it's all software and the
smartest hands over keyboards today
in the world
are developing on the chain and bringing
innovation to financial services which
in the end is the largest sector on
earth that's exactly right kevin
understands that when we get clarity all
of a sudden there's pools of capital
with trillions of dollars that can now
enter into the market right now what
we've seen is individuals a couple of
financial institutions a couple of
publicly traded companies but for the
most part the sovereign wealth funds
many of the most conservative but
largest investors in the world those
trillions of dollars are sitting on the
sidelines they're wondering what is the
government going to do here what are the
rules of the road how can i allocate
without taking unnecessary risk and so
as we start to get the regulatory
clarity both in the united states and
abroad we are going to see an enormous
amount of money pour into this industry
and if it ends up growing large enough
it will become that 12th sector of the s
p
just like during the internet days when
people used to talk about internet
companies and non-internet companies
eventually they all ended up on the
internet 100
of an investor's equity portfolio is
full of internet companies today that's
what's gonna happen with bitcoin and
crypto as well
today it's bitcoin companies and
non-bitcoin companies but over time
every single company in your portfolio
will become a bitcoin or crypto company
and that's exactly why investors like
kevin o'leary and many others are so
interested in this industry if you can
front run the big financial institutions
if you can front run the trillions of
dollars that are going to end up flowing
into this industry it's likely pretty
good for your portfolio
and also
all of that money is likely to have to
help the world adopt what has become the
hardest soundest money in the world hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time